ja schönen guten morgen aus moskau es
ist tatsächlich in der sekunde
losgegangen gerade sehen wir die ersten
schritte auf dem roten platz das ist
noch nicht die parade selbst das ist
jetzt zunächst mal die russische
staatsflagge und das banner des sieges
da sieht man hammer und sichel drauf das
banner des sieges von 1945 das wird
jetzt auf den roten platz getragen
so beginnt hier der erste teil dieser
quasi vor parade in der der
verteidigungsminister des landes
die formation abnimmt
[Musik]
wer hier
die beiden jungen männer die die flaggen
tragen haben monatelang üben müssen
täglich mehrere stunden
sie haben eine exakte schrittzahl
vorgegeben 120 schritte
minute 350 meter tragen sie die flagge
über den platz und da muss jeder schritt
sitzt
[Musik]
absolutes paraden wetter auch heute hier
in moskau
[Musik]
die musik die wir hören heißt heiliger
krieg tatsächlich das ist ein ganz
berühmtes patriotisches lied mir
[Musik]
für präsident putin wir im sahen ein
ganz wichtiger tag heute er hat dieser
liebesgeschichte dem sowjetrussland über
hitler deutschland ja noch mal neue
bedeutung geben historisch für ihn und
für das ganze land ist das eher
definierende feiertag der die
faszinierende historische ereignis für
das selbstverständnis des landes jetzt
[Musik]
die flagge mit dem kaum zu erkennen in
hammer und sichel dort ist nicht die
original sieges flagge es ist eine
flagge eine kopie des original ist am
museum aber sie hat ganz genauso
ausgesehen damals das ist eine frage die
man über dem reichstag ist glaube ich
auch sogar jedenfalls die flagge die
1945 vier auch styling präsentiert wurde
[Musik]
und jetzt werden wir gleich den
verteidigungsminister sehen der in einem
wagen
diese parade abnehmen wird
[Musik]
alles inszeniert wie in einem
hollywoodfilm
da kommt sergej schoigu und er
bekreuzigt sich an dieser stelle wundert
man sich auch es geht ja eigentlich um
einen sowjetischen sieg aber angeblich
hat an dieser stelle hier mal in langer
vorzeit eine kirche gestanden war eine
ikone sogar später versteckt vor den
sowjets und deswegen bekreuzigt man sich
hier jetzt das auto übrigens ist ein bus
aus sowjetischer produktion
[Musik]
der mann im irak gehört haben ist der
chef des heeres der seine truppen hier
präsentieren auch jetzt wieder richtig
wichtig die musik der sprecher erklärt
gerade dass es ein original lied ist das
1945 hier auch bei der parade erklang
[Musik]
bei der original parade 1945 saßen
verteidigungsminister und jedes chef auf
pferden
[Musik]
dann haben sie also auf ihren pferden
gewendet und jetzt geht das alles mit
diesen vaterländischen autos so nennt
man sie hier also russische produktion
august früher nahm man westliche wagen
falls sie sich wundern wieso gerade
stehen können da gibt es eine
haltevorrichtung in den autos an denen
sie sich ganz unmerklich festhalten
können
[Musik]
da sehen wir schon die historischen
uniformen es werden heute auch
historische kompanien mit maschinen in
den uniformen originalgetreuen
nachgenäht
[Musik]
der verteidigungsminister wird die
truppen abfahren abnehmen und wird dann
rapport erstatten beim
oberkommandierenden bei präsident putin
und der wird bei dieser gelegenheit dann
eine rede halten
[Musik]
so passiert ist so vermuten die waste
watcher
[Musik]
interessanterweise sind die 13.000
soldaten die wir heute mit marschieren
werden ohne masken soweit ich das sehen
kann bei den generalproben und bei den
proben hier die es vorher in der stadt
und auch vor der stadt gegeben hat trug
man jeweils maske
[Musik]
während der proben waren sie streng
isoliert jede einheit in getrennten
unterkünften man durfte nicht
untereinander in kontakt treten hat man
sehr genau darauf geachtet
[Musik]
das minimiert
wenn es um die kurse jetzt wurden nicht
ziemlich ist sergej schoigu der
verteidigungsminister ist seit 2012 im
amt
er ist einer der beliebtesten politiker
des landes er gilt als kerl aus dem volk
er war vorher schon sehr auffällig als
minister für katastrophenschutz und ist
nun schon anpacker man mag ihn hier sehe
und in umfragen kommt der regelmäßig
fast an die beliebtheitswerte von
präsident putin randi im moment übrigens
gar nicht suchen sind aber da werde ich
später noch mehr zu erzählen
durch sein wird diesen
in kleineren maßstab finden solche
paraden heute in vielen städten des
landes statt allerdings nicht in so
vielen wie das verteidigungsministerium
und wohl auch präsident putin sich
gewünscht hätten mehr als 30 städte und
regionen haben die feierlichkeiten
abgesagt oder aber lassen sie ohne
publikum stattfinden
wegen corona natürlich in weiten teilen
des landes ist die korona epidemie er
noch überhaupt nicht gekämpft wir haben
immer noch steigende fallzahlen in
vielen regionen
deswegen ist man da lieber vorsichtig
[Musik]
übrigens hatte auch die queen die man ja
neuerdings aus russischer sicht die
annektierte krim zu russland zählt
versucht die parade abzusagen
dort probleme mit corona aber da hat man
ganz schnell sie offensichtlich eines
anderen überzeugt ganz kurz darauf hieß
es schon wieder ab nebel machen sie nun
doch also das ist glaube ich hier der
führung sehr wichtig dass das
ausgerechnet auf der krim auch eine
parade stattfindet auf der krim der
ukrainisch ist aber aus russischer sicht
zu russland gehört
frühchen
den tränen
wie seht ihr das nicht liebe gesetzt
und jetzt fährt der verteidigungs
minister schoigu richtung
oberkommandierenden der russischen
streitkräfte richtung präsident putin
[Musik]
da will ich will kann man durch den
genosse oberkommandierender und gestand
dass die truppen bereit sind
jetzt hören wir den präsidenten zu
[Musik]
general
premiere
[Musik]
eine sehr patriotische rede des
russischen präsidenten und die
nationalhymne jetzt beginnt der
eigentliche teil der parade der
sogenannte marsch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
uns ist die faszination einer solchen
militärischen geschichte fremd ich nicht
mehr so ganz zu vermitteln dass das
wirklich etwas ist was hier
beinahe heilig ist den menschen nicht
nur diese parade sondern
will ich das nicht
an
[Musik]
da sehen wir wieder den chef des heeres
den armeegeneral der eben auch an den
verteidigungsminister die truppen quasi
ins präsentierten vergeben präsident
putin sitzt inmitten von
weltkriegsveteranen das ist ebenso
leicht während der rede aufgefallen
hier ist jetzt gerade der serbische
präsident bush der ganz frisch nach
seinem wald gekommen ist aber die
älteren herrschaften mit denen und gehen
auf der tribüne sitzt sind alle szenen
aus
bei bieren
das ist
[Musik]
so kaputt ist das ist ganz wichtig sie
wenn man das motto
bei den berliner museen
da bis jetzt nur noch reparaturen
gemacht
sind
die stage fußballer der welt
die city friend of medicine
[Musik]
da sehen wir die historischen kompanien
mit den stammdaten der einzelnen
abschnitte durch damals gekämpft haben
die karelische höheres abschnitt zwar
gleich vorneweg habe ich gesehen
man hat ihnen tatsächlich uniformen
gemäht wie exakt im historischen
entsprechen man hat lange heißt es sogar
nach dem stoffen gesucht die genau
passen mussten und man hat ihnen auch
historische waffen zur verfügung
gestellte soll alles genauso aussehen
wie 1945
die wir mitbringen
papier und institute
[Musik]
nochmal dieser sieg im zweiten weltkrieg
den man hier ja den großen
vaterländischen krieg nennt hat eine
immense bedeutung für das land aber auch
für die leute selbst 27 millionen
sowjetbürger sind damals umgekommen
und längst nicht alle kämpfen sehr viele
sind umgebracht worden von den deutschen
besatzern im land nicht nur russen
sondern auch angehörige aller anderen
sowjet völker einen sehr hohen blutzoll
haben ukrainer und weißrussen bezahlt
die auf dem weg der wehrmacht ja die
ersten bahnen
und natürlich hat das eine bedeutung es
gibt keine familie die man im krieg
verloren hätte das bild bis heute
aufrechterhalten das gedenken daran dass
es nie wieder krieg ist etwas das vielen
menschen hier sehr sehr wichtig ist
natürlich wird dieses weltkriegs
gedanken denken jetzt auch
instrumentalisiert ich habe schon gesagt
das ist die wichtigste basis des
russischen selbstverständnisses bis
heute man sieht sich in der nachfolge
der rücken und in der nachfolge der
sowjetunion und zelebrierten sie jedes
jahr aufs neue und so groß wie in diesem
jahr zum 75 jahrestag hat man das machen
[Musik]
derweil gibt die ließen sich hier als zu
alle teilnehmenden soldaten hier sind
übrigens regelmäßig medizinisch
untersucht worden sagt man man hat ihnen
regelmäßig immer offenbar hat man sie
getestet auf dem hohner man hat man hat
sie war gemessen jeden morgen und jeden
abend also da hat man doch sehr große
vorkehrungen getroffen weil es natürlich
viel kritik daran gab dennoch jetzt die
parade durchzuführen nicht noch ein paar
monate zu die veteranen mit jedem guten
auf der tribüne sitzt wie gesagt kann es
weltkriegs veteranen sind in quarantäne
gewesen bevor man sie auf der bühne
gelassen hatten sind zwei monate lang
zwei wochen lang entschuldigung zum teil
in sanatorien zum teil zu hause isoliert
gewesen um dann tatsächlich nicht
infiziert zu sein wenn sie hier in der
nähe von präsident gut
da hat man also genauer vorkehrungen
getroffen
[Musik]
sami khedira
putin hat selbst in der rede gesagt es
kommen sind also auch soldaten anderer
republiken anderer staaten dabei hier
sehen wie aserbaidschan
der aserbaidschanische präsident selbst
ist nicht gekommen
er war eingeladen hat aber wegen der
korona situation in seinem land abgesagt
der armenische präsident ist auch nicht
da der es selbst infiziert also auch in
den gus staaten ist das virus ein großes
problem im moment das ist aber sicher
nicht nicht der einzige grund weshalb
recht wenig staatsgäste sind sind die
meisten der bus staatschefs mehr aber
ansonsten da sehen wir gerade alexander
lukaschenko der übrigens mit drei söhnen
da ist sein jüngerer sohn beginnen so
angeschnitten links neben nicolai das
ist er musste auch jetzt schon so 17 18
sein
lukaschenko selbst zeigte wie man gerne
als einen produkts allen nachfolger wir
sehen die indien die indische formation
die da ist
lukaschenko ist also mit allen drei
söhnen da einer von den gut staatschefs
gehen wir sind ansonsten ist der
serbische präsident da wir haben ihn
schon so lieben sind die chefs der
beiden abtrünnigen georgischen
resultierenden in russland zu einer
unabhängigkeit verholfen hat die
allerdings aus man kaum jemand anerkennt
abchasien und südossetien die beiden
sind da und ansonsten kaum jemand es
sind vor allem wie gesagt staatschefs
der usa
das hat natürlich zu tun ist der die
restlichen staatschefs sind auch bei den
letzten parade - zugegen gewesen viele
von ihnen weil wie gesagt haben wegen
der annexion der clip kann man nicht
mehr auf der tribüne sitzen
angela merkel die deutsche kanzlerin war
eingeladen auch dieses jahr ursprünglich
für den 9
und dann wurde die parade ja verschoben
und jetzt im juni hat sie absagen lassen
mit der begründung dass sie jetzt im
juni noch keine auslandsreisen formen
also corona war da der angegebene grund
und das haben sehr viele andere
staatschefs
[Musik]
du wirst du lebt weiter berichtete und
diese szene wird
das stimmte nicht
das ist auch die mongolei hat seine
parade einheit geschickt
sie vertrage jacobi limitiert da klassik
durch
immer wieder sehen wir gut stehen neu
gewählten präsidenten serbiens
hier laufen seine soldaten das haben wir
gerade gesehen dass er in ein zeichen
gegeben hat
wohin
das ist ja bei uns tätig ist
soll ich sie noch einmal
wir haben
doch minis tagen gerade vorher haben wir
tadschikistan gesehen zwei starten die
auch sehr mit comes to register
sid
das skore
kubicki
[Musik]
heute dann ist
was kosten
babysitter
dieser ist mit dem gut
die musst du den
die gegeben
die weltkriegs veteranen wie aus der
kabine sitzen das kann man sich
ausrechnen sind alle über 19
die sich geht und ich glaube dass auch
deshalb es hier den dem kreml so schwer
gefallen ist die parade zu verschieben
vom neunten mal oder möglicherweise ganz
ausfallen lassen zu müssen gegen korona
ist auch da dem geschuldet dass es hier
möglicherweise der letzte runde
jahrestag ist an dem noch aktive
teilnehmer des weltkriegs bei der parade
zu lesen sein können es gibt den angaben
des verteidigungsministeriums zufolge
noch etwa 40.000 die menschen im land
wie im zweiten weltkrieg als soldat
gekämpft haben
es gibt sehr viel mehr die anderweitig
betroffen waren die soldaten bitten zum
beispiel
menschen die als zwangsarbeiter in
deutscher gefangenschaft bahn
[Musik]
das sind noch mehr als 100000 aber es
wird natürlich von jedem jahr will
die nächsten runden jahrestag während
weltkriegs kann sagen ja
[Musik]
wo ist
und schon ist
das ist die hütte
das ist
wir haben gerade eben bei den militär
schülern der raketenstreitkräfte die in
rot gekleidet waren auch frauen
maschinen sehen ja es gibt frauen in der
russischen armee
es herrscht wehrpflicht hier die gilt
nur für männer frauen arbeiten in denen
in anführungsstrichen früher als
klassische weibliche berufe gesehenen
bereichen die arbeiten im medizinischen
bereich in der versorgung aber es gibt
frauen in der russischen armee
das ist sein wunsch über jede woche
sehen
die spezialisten
ich sage jeden
bis zur logistik
allerdings ist hier noch spezielle
dienste für der kritik
von der statistik
so groß wie in diesem jahr war die
parade noch nicht sie ist da unter
präsident putin immer größer geworden er
hat ihr sehr viel mehr gewicht
beigemessen als noch sein vorgänger geld
sind putin war derjenige der auch die
panzer zurückgeholt hat die schwere
technik auf dem roten platz unter jelzin
waren nur noch soldaten marschiert aber
putin hat das geändert und hat auch dies
genutzt um die technik vorzuzeigen mit
den zweiten teil dieser heutigen parade
markieren
in diesem mal sind das habe ich schon
gesagt 13.000 soldaten dabei das sind
mehr denn je aber es ist ja auch ein
besonderer jahrestag 75 jahre nach dem
sieg der roten armee über nazi
deutschland
[Musik]
super plus
richtig ist und sonst
[Musik]
es gibt keine
musst du nicht mit
[Musik]
meinst du
es gab ich habe es schon angedeutet sehr
viel kritik und stirnrunzeln ob der
entscheidung diese parade nun doch
bereits im juni statt in diese lassen
[Musik]
der eigentliche termin ist der 9 mai der
tag des sieges ein großer feiertag hier
in russland in diesem jahr so wie gesagt
wegen corona nicht machbar dass man an
diesem tag eine parade abmelde
man hat dann überlegt welche
möglichkeiten es gibt man hat nach
anderen historischen daten gesucht das
hätte spätere im september gebeten da
gab es einige möglichkeiten der
demission tage zu finden dann wenn man
diese parade abhält der frühestmögliche
war dieser 24 ct ja genau der tag ist
der historische tag an dem damals die
erste sind ist parade statt
es ist am 24 juni 1955 italien auf der
tribüne überwinden mausoleums wurde hier
die erste sieben erst anderthalb wochen
nach dem andern verhinderte nach den
sieg aber das hat natürlich auch damit
zu tun dass die kämpfer das den soldaten
her erst mal zurückkommen musste nach
moskau
wenn ich deswegen hat man nicht gleich
im mai eine parade abhalten können man
muss sie ja erst mal wieder zurückholen
wahrscheinlich aber erst mal wieder
ankommen
das titelthema
von der parade damals gibt es witzige
weise zwei fernsehaufzeichnungen die
erste in schwarzweiß das ist die
original parade von diesen 24 juni
damals hat es geregnet die bilder war
nicht sehr schön die gefielen stalin
nicht also hat man die ganze parade noch
einmal wiederholt hat sie dann in farbe
aufgenommen bei besserem wetter und das
ist die version die man findet wenn man
jetzt im internet zum beispiel nach
paraden bildern sucht also man hat
versucht die alte gibt es auch noch aber
man hat sie es auch damals schon aufs
bild geachtet und wollte ich schon
das nun dieser frühe termin gesucht
wurde hat sich das politische runde dass
man bereits im jungen diese parade
abhängt dass der immer noch drohenden
corona gefahr russland ist ja das land
mit den meisten fällen von corona wir
haben 600.000 mittlerweile infektion das
leben hand in moskau gibt es täglich
1000 neues im ganzen land immer so
zwischen sind 8000 neue leben tag das
ist nicht wenig und dennoch hat man sich
entschieden jetzt bereits diesen
feiertag nachzuholen das hat sicher
damit zu tun
das auch ein zweites ereignis das
geplant war
für den mai ausfallen musste für ende
april schon ohne volksbefragung zu einer
neuen verfassung die hier schon
verabschiedet ist wie man aber dem volk
noch einmal vorliegen will damit noch
das volk die wut heißt obwohl sie schon
in kraft ist man wollte glaube ich für
diese abstimmung eine gute stimmung
haben eine stimmung ist ja doch sehr
düster wegen der langen corona lockdown
zeiten hier und man wollte eine
optimistische patriotischen stimmung für
diese verfassungs abstimmung ist wie ab
morgen beginnt eine woche lang können
dann wird dann hier abgestimmt der
eigentliche abstimmungstag ist der erste
juli aber ab morgen kann man schon
abstimmen
und aus sicht des kreml ist die parade
sicher der richtige auftakt in die leute
im abstimmen
dann bei dir
kloten
nächster nähe
[Musik]
mit
die kreativen
es ist für soldaten eine riesen ehre
hier mitmachen zu dürfen
die sind handverlesen und sie haben
monatelang dass das alles so sitzt die
es hier sind jeder schritt sitzt
das ist schon unglaublich
dr
dazu
die produziert werden
viel zu wenige
[Musik]
die moskauer sind übrigens aufgerufen
worden vom bürgermeister und sogar von
putins pressesprecher sich die parade
doch lieber zuhause anzuschauen im
fernsehen üblicherweise säumen die
menschen wie die straßen wenn die wenn
die soldaten und auch die panzer
aufmarschieren zum roten platz und auch
selbst nachher wenn sie wenn sie zurück
fahren in ihrer einheiten nicht mehr im
ferrari formation
dennoch stehen hier immer unglaublich
viele menschen so man hat sie aufgerufen
das dieses jahr nicht zu tun also offen
weiß man doch auch besorgt wegen gucken
hat
ich glaube das wichtigste ist auch dass
diese bilder hier so im fernsehen
flimmern ins ganze land sämtliche
russische fernsehkanäle übertragen das
holte sämtlichen staaten die pläne und
man kann sicher sein dass es nur wenige
russen geben wird die diese bilder heute
nichts und darum geht es
[Musik]
die seiten dieses durch die tür auf
werden
es ist
diese
luftlandetruppen immer erkennbar an den
blauen käppis dafür dass die partie
hast du leben
diese ringelhemd die die fragen sind
übrigens fester bestandteil einer
russischen militär uniformen das sind so
genannte pillen yaz nicht jetzt hat lang
waren die mal richtig lieb ihr da druck
man die einfach als sonne sonne angesagt
bekleidung jeder soldat hat diese
geringelten händen unter der uniform
bis 7
sie ist so dr
wo ist denn jetzt so unendliches
gerechnet
so wird sie lieben
für die fans
mehrere millionen
das
die tun
chemische und biologische kamen waren
dass gerade die wiese vorbei marschieren
sagen und dass wir sind die verbindung
soll
die lager der gegenüber turin festigt
gemeinden
bei der verfassungsänderungen über die
das volk ab morgen abstimmen soll oder
zumindest sie diese gut heißen soll
entschieden ist sie schon wird es unter
anderem auch darum gehen dass präsident
putin nicht an die zwei amtszeiten
gebunden ist dies weil der jetzigen
verfassung immer noch als vor schluss
gibt er kann sich ein weiteres und noch
ein weiteres mal zum präsidenten wählen
lassen
er hat neulich gesagt dass er auch
darüber nachdenke dass er nun
entschieden habe aber die möglichkeit
bestehe dass diese theoretisch könnte
präsident putin dann bis 2036 im amt
bleiben das wären dann 36 jahre an der
macht
hieß es
eine hexe
wenig
[Musik]
auch das ministerium für
katastrophenschutz hat truppen die
marschieren hier gerade vorbei
13 sitzen gehen
ständig werden
da man die
die
[Musik]
das
in der neuen verfassung wird auch einen
passus stehen dass die historische
wahrheit geleugnet werden darf ist also
ist eine so genannte schutz der
historischen wahrheit ist wird dann
strafbar sein
historische wahrheit zu verbiegen was
die historische wahrheit ist wird
allerdings dann hier definiert und einen
kleinen vorgeschmack hat uns präsident
putin gegeben er hat einen historischen
artikel verfasst in dem er noch mal das
wiederholt was auch zu sowjetzeiten
immer argumentiert wurde dass bohlen nur
mit schuld ist am ausbruch des
weltkrieges und im endeffekt auch daran
dass es dann aufgeteilt wurde zwischen
hitler und stalin hoch umstritten im
westen natürlich
und er hat auch geschrieben und das ist
das was ganz neu bei wo sich viele
erschrocken haben das die baltischen
staaten ab der vertrag freiwillig der
sowjetunion beigetreten seien wohingegen
aus sicht der üblichen
geschichtsschreibung
wollten natürlich gezwungen worden dass
bei der addition der baltischen staaten
litauen ist lettlands und estlands in
diese wertung nun da hat man doch
aufgehorcht und sich gefragt wie denn
die historische wahrheit durch russlands
präsidenten demnächst
die motive
mustafi
beliebter
ich habe mal einen jungen mann
kennengelernt der hiermit marschiert ist
vor einigen jahren und er hat erzählt
dass er es verflucht hat also trainieren
musste aber als dann der moment an dem
er über diesen roten platz liegt vorbei
an seinem präsidenten den er sehr
verehrt muss ist das ein ganzer haben
der moment gewesen sei den er sein leben
lang nicht vergessen werde und da sein
dann sämtliche türen des langen
trainings vergessen gewesen ich glaube
das ist ganz schön was los und es
beginnt der teil der schau wir sehen die
franz erfahren
rechts am historischen museum vorbei auf
den großen platz gab es eine andere
pflanze aufmarsch strecke noch zu
sowjetzeiten
die hat jetzt hin zu bauen lassen mit
einer kleinen kirche weil er gesagt hat
es sollen keine panzer mehr auf den
roten platz meine paraden werde ich
abhalten lassen nur mit marschierenden
soldaten jetzt fahren sie einen anderen
leben nämlich diesen wiedersehen denn
präsident putin hat entschieden
sie werden wieder da sehen wir einen
historischen weltkriegs panzer es sind
ja zwei modelle aus dem weltkrieg ii
vertreten der t 34 und der s100 vor
allem t 34 waren ganz gefürchtete panzer
hier sehen wir einen
obwohl kriegsentscheidend waren die
damals erneuerbaren wie sowjetunion
hatte eine neue technologie entwickelt
die sehr einfach zusammen bauen zu
können es konnte eine massenproduktion
starten und das war sicherlich einer der
entscheidenden faktoren
heute werden die wegen der beinahe
verehrt hier diese panzer es gibt ganze
spielplätze zu tina wohl nachbauten
bläser weltkriegs panzer stehen und die
kinder begeistert drauf spielen sehr
bedenklich aus unserer sicht natürlich
es gibt habe ich auch schon gesehen
kleine karussells in denen man in
solchen panzern herum fährt oder so
kleine miniatur version mit denen man
dann eine kleine strecke selbst abfahren
kann also die weltkriegs panzer haben
hier einen ganz besonderen status und ja
wenn man das so sagen kann weil sich
nicht werden und meine
es werden 225 verschiedene arten von
gerätschaft hier unterwegs sein 100
kanzler auch weltfußballer
es wird aber auch die allerneueste
technik dabei sein da ist man sehr stolz
darauf für mich ist das auch eine kleine
premiere muskel
dieses spiel schon einmal das besteck
vor zeigen was man hier so in der
schublade hat zum teil gerät schafft die
noch nicht mal mit fotos bisher bekannt
sind von dem man nur weiß das sie
entwickelt werden so wurde zumindest
hier im vorfeld dafür getrommelt und man
weiß natürlich dass auch militärs in der
ganzen welt hier zuschauen werden
[Musik]
als die navy cis krise
was sollte ich immer gesagt das muss das
ziel ist der judas ist dabei der polizei
wir sind von der fis
irgendwie
[Musik]
si
die
seit dem 7
dabei situation ist
geht
die firma screen
der puffer inklusive
die neuesten armada panzer werden
liegezeit mit
auch setzten die bisher auch noch nicht
gesehen wurden offenbar gerätschaften
die russland auch teilweise jetzt
also einige dieser gerätschaften die wir
hier sehen werden heute werden auch in
syrien eingesetzt zum beispiel da zeigt
man das ist hat sicherlich auch mit den
nebeneffekt das ist eine art von waffen
schau ist möglicherweise auch
potenzielle käufer an russland verkauft
zum gebiet an
ja wahnsinnsbilder hat man
wahrscheinlich häufig geübte und
sinniert wie hollywood er bei denen die
beatles tribut
insgesamt werden
juni
die parade wird hier noch etwa eine
halbe stunde weitergehen
wir werden allerdings jetzt gleich
abgeben nach düsseldorf denn dort wird
armin laschet dem landtag rede und
antwort stellen in sachen corona wenn
sie die parade weiter verfolgen wollen
schalten sie jetzt um ins internet
phoenix de wir werden weiter
kommentieren
und sie können dann mit uns gemeinsam
das spektakel weiter verfolgen bis zum
ende
etwa gegen halb elf deutscher zeiten
ja die linie
uns tut sie
st
ich denke die dich rufen
kundenservice samstag es die polizei
essen
das teleskop hubble
er solle lte ist am sonntag sie meinen
hinterließen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen nochmal auch hier
jetzt online wir machen weiter mit der
parade wir sind im zweiten teil und wir
sehen
neueste
aber ich muss zwischendurch immer zu
hören um zu verstehen was da gerade sehr
die russland zeigt seine neueste
militärtechnik hier wir kennen die
reihenfolge im vorfeld nicht ganz genau
wann welche gerätschaften kommen
also hieß es
das hier sind es kann der raketen
komplexe solche wie russland sie in
kaliningrad stationiert hat die stehen
da dieser wie den den nato soldaten die
ja rotierend im baltikum tätig sind
die grenze
positiver weise zu spielen
dass der
fällig sei
luftabwehr eine neue entwicklung der das
buch kastensystems den namen kennt man
nach ansicht der internationalen
ermittlungsbehörde ist die devise der
ermittlungsgruppe im abschuss von emh 17
dem malaysischen passagierjet über der
ost ukraine ist es erwiesen dass ein
system russischer provenienz die
maschine abgeschossen
[Musik]
das ist so
ausgegeben
die wette
ausgenommen
mit
mehr als 220 einheiten militärischer
fahrzeuge paraden hier am russischen
präsidenten vor bei so viel wie noch nie
die neueste waffentechnik wird
vorgezeigt auch wirtschaft für die noch
nie jemand gesehen hat in den russischen
zeitungen hat man die proben besucht und
hat versucht auf den proben bereits zu
erkennen was denn die neue technik ist
wie sie aussieht es gab da ganze
diskussionen darüber also auch die
militärexperten hier die nicht
eingeweihten sind sehr gespannt was da
heute alles gezeigt werden
[Musik]
das lied kennen sie
katjuscha ein russisches kriegsschiff
die schülerin
so nah
das szenario
bis zu leben
nicht nur russland hält solche
siegesparaden ab auch viele der anderen
ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken jetzt
eigenständige staaten machen dass
weißrussland belarus mit präsident
lukaschenko an der spitze hat eine große
parade abgehalten sogar am jahrestag
selbst am 9
er hat sich nicht abhalten lassen trotz
grüner auch in belarus sind die
fallzahlen sehr hoch aber er hat es
durch gezogen und hat gesagt das sei er
dem andenken an die schuldigen in vielen
russischen regionen soll das auch
stattfinden aber da haben doch ab bis zu
30 regionen abgesagt dass man das nicht
machen wolle dass partie hier sehen ist
übrigens ein kriegsgerät das in diese
sehen so ähnlich eingesetzt das eine
oder andere anschuldigungen zurück und
militärische fachbegriffe ist immer der
wahnsinn eine eine gerade mal nachsehen
wie das ding genau heißt das ist ein
ganz mächtiger flammenwerfer der mit
unterdruck arbeitet und ganze dörfer
vernichten kann ist man sehr stolz
darauf hier es gibt eine neue variante
davon die heute vorgezeigt wird das
heißt das system und ist
also hierfür nicht nur sachen die man
einfach auf dem schrank holt und vorteil
weil man sie auf lager hat nein hier
sind gerätschaften die sind tatsächlich
liegend im moment
für die gute stimmung
im blick
russland ist ja auch einer der
wichtigsten waffenexport kommt bei
weitem nicht an die usa ran aber
verkaufen viele waffen in die welt und
da ist so eine parade natürlich auch
noch mal eine gute gelegenheit vor zu
zeigen was man ihr so alles
medizin
die sie unterwegs
[Musik]
foto hin
der sprecher im russischen fernsehen der
die parade kommentiert sagt gerade ja
auch diese gerätschaften und werden in
syrien eingesetzt haben sich dort als
sehr effektiv sagt er
sie sehen die kleinen kinder in uniform
weltkriegs gedenken ist etwas das
beginnt schon im kindergarten und
bereits im kindergarten lernen die
kinder was dieser sieg bedeutet und
lernen einen stolz darauf zu entwickeln
es gibt eltern die das mittel finden ich
habe auch für eltern im bekanntenkreis
die sagen sie möchten eigentlich nicht
dass ihre kinder mission militärischen
verständnis von vaterland aufwachsen
aber es gibt kaum eine möglichkeit sich
dem zu entziehen das geht dann in der
schule weiter unsere kinder sind
tatsächlich schon als kleine kinder sehr
genau im bilde was dieser sieg bedeutet
und sie weiß das ganze hat natürlich
auch eine sehr wichtige komponente dann
ehrt das andenken der großväter der
urgroßväter man er ehrt die oder man
kennt die gefallenen und umgekommenen in
der eigenen familie
man ist zum teil auch stolz darauf dass
man in der eigenen familie gekämpft hat
all das gehört auch dazu
aber eben auch diese wie sie doch
militärische bewusstsein von vaterland
und vom vater lange stolz
du weißt du wie kannst du sie was muss
ich sehe wie toni
liegt das daran
[Musik]
der dritte und letzte teil der parade
ist die flugshow oder die luft parade
mehr als 75 flugzeuge und hubschrauber
sind in der luft zu kommen jetzt auch
hier über unser studio geflogen
auf dem weg zum roten platz wir sind ja
gar nicht weit vom roten platz entfernt
und werden jetzt bei perfektem wetter
einmal hier vorbei bebens an den gästen
am präsidenten bislang
der teppich die sonst riskiert
schließlich hätte die option
wir sind ein t shirt
die durch die politik
das größte transport der größe
transporthubschrauber der welt sagt der
sprecher gerade mi 28
heute sind
die durch ihren inhalt
das ist ja das war
wie durch die gruppe
teile der innenstadt sind übrigens
abgesperrt heute vormittag das wird auch
nach der parade noch eine zeit lang so
bleiben die ganze technik muss ja wieder
abziehen die ziele durch die innenstadt
abbiegen und wir werden dann gleich
sehen ob viele menschen gekommen sind
trotz der empfehlung lieber am fernsehen
zu schauen
wahnsinn mit kleinen kameras im cockpit
könnte dann jeweils auch gesehen das ist
toll gemacht
wegen
polizisten sind also gewarnt
die titel abnehmen
noch ist der vertragstext
dieses system z
das hauptinteresse
hier wird die kampfkraft der flugzeuge
gepriesen die gleichzeitig bis zu 50
ziele angreifen können dass ihr mann
schluckt immer wenn man das hört doch
sehr ungewöhnlich für unsere ohren denn
so mit kampfkraft geworben wird
aber mir ist das ganz normal man ist
stolz darauf was man vorführen kann was
man hat was man vielleicht auch
verkaufen können
das ist ja
alles super league
und wir sehen ein tank manöver in der
luft
bist du allein
das kommt
in die tiefe
die besteht
ihr mann an
und dieses wissen sie bitte ddp
mit die unternehmen können
ok
die pd
die hatte
aus der luft zu sehen ist es doch sehr
viel lehrer auf dem roten platz als
gewöhnlich man hat die tribünenplätze
sehr begrenzt
man versuche möglichst ja
sicher der kommune gefahr hier
anzupassen
die wirklichen
komik
dies liegt
und da sehen wir die russische trikolore
zum ende der parade
das ist
[Musik]
sehen sie dass die straßen in moskau
leer sind man hat tatsächlich abgesperrt
um die technik später abziehen lassen zu
können da sehen wir auch schon kanzler
die zurückfahren
rechts unten im bild
[Musik]
das ist die hymne des sieges tages
sie heißt der tag des sieges und ein
großes orchester aus mehreren
bestandteilen russischer
militärorchester bestehen
zum abschluss der parade gibt diesen tag
des sieges zum besten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist freude mit tränen in den augen
lässt eine der zeilen dieses liedes und
möglicherweise wird jetzt auch
präsidentin emotional für ihn ist diese
sache eine sehr emotionale sicherlich
einerseits aus persönlicher erfahrung
seiner familie aber auch weil dies ein
feiertag ist er hat diesen tag des
sieges zu seinem feiertag gemacht zu
seinem wichtigsten feiertage seines
landes mit dem er sich ganz eng
verbunden fühlt und das spürt man bei
jedem seiner auftritte
auch deshalb vielleicht kann er sich so
schlecht von der macht rennen auch
deshalb lässt er sich jetzt der
verfassung die möglichkeit geben weiter
kandidieren zu gast
[Musik]
es wird noch eine feierstunde geben
jetzt mit den ausländischen staatsgästen
auch mit den veteranen und heute abend
gibt es traditionell ein großes
feuerwerk in der stadt
die parade ist beendet wladimir putin
geht mit seinen gästen zurück in den
kreml